thank you Sam hey guys I'm Rita and it's
great to be here at hustle con now I
just have a few minutes up here so I
thought I'd share with you guys just one
lesson that zenefits has learned about
hustle which is the importance of
clearly defining your target market
let's see if we can get the clicker to
work there we go Oh can I get oh there
we go perfect all right so before I jump
in really quickly for those of you who
don't know a lot about what Sena fits
does we solved this problem that I think
pretty much every business owner in the
US has which is that you have 20
different systems related HR you have
health insurance you have payroll you
have time and attendance and because all
of those systems are disconnected every
time you need to hire or terminate
somebody you have to add or remove them
from 20 different places right every
time somebody changes their address you
have to update that in 20 different
places so what and that creates this
huge administrative load that the HR
departments and most companies have to
deal with
so what zenefits does is we take all
those different systems we connect them
and we give companies and their
employees a single place to do
everything which makes which takes a lot
of work and a lot of time off their
plates now because this problem that I
described of all of these different
disconnected systems is a problem that
just about every company in the US has
what we found it's in if it was that
customers of all different shapes and
sizes that's we're knocking on our door
we found ourselves serving everybody
from a seven-person tech startup to a
1,000 person healthcare consulting firm
and everything in between even though
they all have slightly different needs
and you know it's really tempting when
you raise a lot of money and you have a
really big vision to think that you can
do everything all at once but the
reality is that no matter how many
resources you have and how big you are
companies execute better when they
ruthlessly prioritize and then sequence
their efforts so we asked ourselves is
there a you know should we better define
our target market is there a specific
market that we should focus on first
before we expand from there and if so
how should we define that should that be
based on geography based on customer
size based on customer vertical based on
something different and I know this is a
question that some of you guys might be
thinking about now or some of you guys
might need to think about in the future
so I'll share with you how we approached
it we took a look at our customer base
and we thought a lot about product
market fit and we looked at a bunch of
internal data and it became pretty clear
that for us it made sense to define our
target market based on customer size and
more specifically that we should focus
on the small business market there we go
we should focus on a small business
market or companies with under 100
employees for a few different reasons
one is that it's a huge market so there
are over six million small businesses in
the United States but it's also a market
which is really underserved by
technology so typically our main
competitor is an Excel spreadsheet in
addition the free aspect of our product
was particularly compelling for small
companies we felt that we could have the
most impact with small businesses
because they typically don't even have
one HR person to manage this big
administrative burden and then from a
product perspective the needs of this
segment are the least complex to serve
and to build a robust feature set for so
whether we looked at all of those
factors or we looked at our internal
data like sales cycles and closed rates
and retention rates it was pretty clear
that for us we would outperform in the
small business market and so that was a
target market that we should hyper focus
on first
now the broader lesson here that I hope
is helpful for some of you guys who are
here today is that if you find that
you're growing but you're growing in
multiple directions all at the same time
consider instead trying to proactively
define and then dominate a small
but extensible market before you expand
further now this has been a proven
strategy for growth right if we look at
Facebook choosing to focus on just
college campuses or the different
decisions that other companies like
Amazon or Netflix or ever have made they
all chose to start out with just one
vertical or one customer or one
geography before they expanded from
there sort of sequencing their journey
so they could build strength along the
way that's my advice for you I hope this
has been helpful and I wish you all the
very best of luck thank you very much